Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Have you ever wondered how your voice, or
your guitar would sound in the middle of a
space station?
A realistic simulation of sounds within virtual
environments dramatically improves the immersion
of the user in computer games and virtual
reality applications.
To be able to simulate these effects, we need
to compute the interaction between sound waves
and the geometry and materials within the
scene.
If you remember, we also had quite a few episodes
about light simulations, where we simulated
the interaction of light rays or waves and
the scene we have at hand.
Sounds quite similar, right?
Well, kind of, and the great thing is that
we can reuse quite a bit of this knowledge
and some of the equations for light transport
for sound.
This technique we call path tracing, and it
is one of the many well-known techniques used
for sound simulation.
We can use path tracing to simulate the path
of many waves to obtain an impulse response,
which is a simple mathematical function that
describes the reverberation that we hear if
we shoot a gun in a given scene, such as a
space station or a church.
After we obtained these impulse reponses,
we can use an operation called the convolution
with our input signal, like our voice to get
a really convincing result.
We have talked about this in more detail in
earlier episodes, I've put a link for them
in the video description box.
It is important to know that the impulse reponse
depends on the scene and where we, the listeners
are exactly in the scene.
In pretty much every concert ever, we find
that sound reverberations are quite different
in the middle of the arena versus standing
at the back.
One of the main contributions of this work
is that it exploits temporal coherence.
This means that even though the impulse response
is different if we stand at different places,
but these locations don't change arbitrarily
and we can reuse a lot of information from
the previous few impulse reponses that we
worked so hard to compute.
This way, we can get away with tracing much
fewer rays and still get high-quality results.
In the best cases, the algorithm executes
five times as quickly as previous techniques,
and the memory requirements are significantly
more favorable.
The paper also contains a user study.
Limitations include a bit overly smooth audio
signals and some fidelity loss in the lower
frequency domains.
Some of these scenes in the footage showcase
up to 24 distinct sound sources, and all of
them are simulated against the geometry and
the materials found in the scene.
So let's listen together and delight in these
magnificent results.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!